ok next one again woody for to get some
different positions ok place is six ok
let's try and open this million 96 ok
now no no no I'm on my own here ok
castling cannot be that bad so what now
you might play g6 if I don't take on c6
yeah just take here finish the
development maybe this is some too
simplistic against them against the Sun
set up but I don't know really how it is
played
I need to watch out for the five maybe
at some point it could be inconvenient
not sure maybe still preventing be 5k he
goes d5 now I think I can just take two
towers because of no Bishop age seven so
maybe it may be a 4 after all
interesting maybe I can we can really
take on c3 it's possible maybe
okay let's get the Queen over of course
here Queen age 35 I can play f5 yeah I'm
already pretty clearly down on time yeah
it's really difficult to to adjust to
entirely new positions
at least after g6 some I cannot really
take on c3 anymore
wow this looks weakening okay but still
what happens now if i play 5v5 it takes
72 takes then only five I can play AG
attack f5 cannot believe in this okay
let's play this d 5 I can just play on
Bishop c5 and then 92 I think I should I
should have pretty good control of the
position look somewhat like I'm like a
French okay where do I put this now
interesting question maybe even Bishop
d6 yeah I'd like of course I like to
exchange it okay
don't think you can afford something
like Quincy okay okay now switch this
over and b6 assigning now yeah okay what
about king of two okay let's go for this
end game should be M should be ok at
least I have to weakness on on c3 but
otherwise some the position looks really
fine okay
it's surprising here for take now and
edge for
okay i need to block block the pawn and
the techie six I think
time warning discipline for f4 no idea
once again I'm no one time position wise
i think it's it's just good check check
check okay
and I want to get the knight on d4 maybe
chennai g5 maybe this is even better now
get this temple and check e 6 as well
and now we have six to come
yeah the h-bond should be too much
really we won't get any decent
counterplay I think because h7 was just
he cannot move the rock from the seventh
because h7s just deadly then and now I
can just walk the King up to g6 I win
cannot do anything
yeah yeah this is enough even with this
little time yeah cha cha how to check
the check Jesus oh my god what did I do
well at least I'm not losing check check
check stalemate not winning this is
really tough I just played everything
winds of course OOP g7 everything wins I
just I just forgot about the stupid
check here can also just breaking f6 and
take everything okay but i think it was
so I played this okay I think it's
always difficult this completely a
completely different middle games but I
don't other this
this was of course just just bad-bad
transformation after this white is just
better you know